[Musique]
nba
aux jeux centrés sur la grèce mme simon
je ramène ça chez moi ce soir wcd qu'ils
envoient s'est déguisé en quoi vous
devez réfléchir qu'elle offrait
par contre moi
qui
c
mais un sens bien vous est il trop bien
faire
[Musique]
les médias
tiens
c'est pas normal
ce sont des milliers à y
[Musique]
on a fixé à qui il est quelles heures
samedi
[Musique]
attention il est parce que je sais
maintenant c'est bien écrit c'est la
panique à aïeux et du hip hop jésus vint
donc ça s'annonce mais ça non seulement
oui annonce adore ça a mûri
quant à gasquet tous les mélanges en
empêchant que j'ai retiré ma job chez
audi le camp spada fois on sait bien
c'est bien sûr je ne sais pas qui c'est
et comment savoir où chérif rougir il va
beaucoup de talent et un livre ça veut
dire tout le monde fait
moi j'ai du mal à jouer un petit peu de
côté c'est moi qui ai un petit peu ici
et c'est d'abord un nom très bon
[Musique]
oh